when I was 22. I was robbed at gunpoint
head on the floor of a restaurant gunned
to my head a man counting back from
three and telling me when he hit zero
he's going to shoot me in the head
I was sure that I was going to die that
day and I will tell you that I did not
feel fear or sadness or anger the only
feeling I was consumed with was regret I
was 22 years old and I had failed to do
anything with my life that I had wanted
to do
[Music]
hey friends welcome back to Deep dive
the weekly podcast where every week I
sit down with authors entrepreneurs
creators and other inspiring people to
find out how they got to where they are
and the strategies and tools that we can
learn from them to apply to our own
lives now Matthew is the author of this
fantastic book storyworthy He's also an
elementary school teacher in the US he
is also a wedding DJ and an official
officiant at weddings and spend some
time in jail was arrested for a crime he
didn't commit most of the time none of
the rules actually matter most of them
are made up arbitrarily you know I'm not
proposing people Rob but what I'm
proposing is test the world but the
conversation took a lot of weird turns
it's kind of hard to describe the stuff
we talked about but I can honestly say
this has been one of the favorite
conversations I've ever had on this
podcast people ask me like how did you
do all that and work 50 hours a week and
I say after you're homeless and in jail
and you have a gun to your head and you
think you're going to be in prison for
10 years nothing else is hard you know I
was hopeless and all you have to do is
take someone who's hopeless and give
them a little hope and nothing seems as
hard anymore
you've got a ridiculously interesting
life
um you know you've been and and by
interesting I also mean like traumatic
uh in in some ways and as we were doing
research for this podcast people on our
team were like oh my gosh like it sounds
like he's had a really traumatic
upbringing I'm not sure if he's going to
be open to talking about the stuff and I
was kind of chuckling because you write
about this stuff in your books and you
tell this stuff in your stories
um I guess can you for people who might
not know who you are can you give a sort
of spark note summary of what your life
has been and how we've kind of ended up
ended up talking to each other here
sure
I guess we're talking to each other
primarily because I'm a Storyteller
amongst other things you know I'm a
novelist and a writer and a columnist
and 12 years ago
on a whim because my friends sort of
encouraged me to do it I went to New
York City and told a story on a stage in
a in a competition and won and suddenly
discovered something that I enjoyed and
and thought that I would just become a
Storyteller who stood on stages in New
York and Boston and maybe I would be
daring enough to travel somewhere else
someday and tell a story and I thought
that was going to be it and uh last
night I was in New York at the same
competition for the moth sitting there
next to my friend Jenny and she said
it's so weird that now you just consult
with like Fortune 100 companies and
in hospitals and
photojournalists and all of that stuff
and you know so today I do a lot of that
I work with just about every type of
person you can imagine
it's supposed to be storytelling and
sometimes it is but as my wife will tell
you she's sitting in the other room
listening I'll get off a call and she'll
say that had nothing to do with
storytelling you were basically helping
that person navigate their life figure
out a way to handle a co-worker you know
navigate a difficult work situation I
work with a lot of people who
find themselves sort of in work
environments where they can't trust the
people or they can't rely on the people
around them for advice so you know I'm
working with a woman of color in
Corporate America who can't show
weakness in the office because of who
she is around and what she has needed to
do in order to get where she is and
suddenly this guy who is supposed to be
helping with her with a keynote
is also someone who understands how to
listen who has lived a life of
you know many experiences and has some
wisdom and you know I get off the call
and I say well we didn't talk about
storytelling there but I helped her
you know figure out how to deal with her
boss better or I helped her lead her
team you know I'm helping I'm helping a
lot of Executives now on just basically
leadership like how do I get an employee
that I have to do the things I need them
to do and oddly because I've been a
school teacher also for 24 years I'm
able to give those folks advice on how
to change the behavior of the people
they're working with so it is a really
strange life that I have now that that
resonates a lot because
um I remember after I read your book
storyworthy which um I was I I read it
in 2020 and whenever I did my kind of
roundups of the year or things like that
I always said Yep this was the single
best book uh that I've read in 2020 and
it was sick
um and just like although it sort of is
like a how to tell better stories it's
also like just itself an incredibly
moving and powerful and inspirational
and like all of all of the adjectives
type book and then I remember emailing
you
um being like hey do you do one-on-one
coaching because I like the idea of
improving my storytelling and I think we
did one or two sessions about
storytelling and then it immediately
turned into my weekly session with
Matthew is sort of like a combination of
life coaching and therapy and helping me
with my book and helping me helping me
overcome limiting beliefs and stuff
um so that like I'm I'm not surprised
that that is uh the vibe that you have
when you when you when you work with
other people as well
um I guess while we're on this topic
what are some of the problems that you
know when when you're Consulting someone
who's a leader at a Fortune 100 company
or when you're Consulting someone like
me or when you consider like you know
people across across a wide range of
things I guess what are the common
problems that our listeners might be
able to relate to that you find come up
um kind of time and time again
confidence is an enormous problem for a
lot of people I I find that there's a
lot of self-doubt in the world and
there's an enormous belief that everyone
is looking at everyone you know the
spotlight effect the idea that
if you come to work and you have a bad
hair day everyone's going to know you
had a bad hair day or if you're in a
meeting and you say the wrong thing
everyone will forever remember that
thing and and that is a debilitating
belief that a lot of people have where
they can't move through life without
constantly worrying about what happened
five minutes ago and so I work really
hard with people to sort of Encompass
and embrace the idea that
no one pays as much attention to you as
you think they do and when you release
that worry and that concern you can
become enormously happy and more
productive because suddenly all the
things that you're doing to sort of
maintain an image that is utterly
unnecessary once all those things Fall
Away you suddenly find yourself free
both in terms of the bandwidth you have
to be thinking about the things you want
to do but also just frankly time you
know I am obsessive about minutes and I
am obsessive about the idea that people
waste their minutes on things that no
one notices nobody cares and don't lead
them in the right direction so that is a
real struggle for people
just confidence it's an enormous problem
for a lot of people
so the idea that yeah you know people
aren't thinking about you as much as you
think they are uh most people would kind
of Nod when they hear that in theory
um and I've given that advice so many
times and yet I also then spend
inordinate amounts of time worrying that
oh that thing that I said at that party
where I kind of made a joke and it kind
of went a bit flat was that a bit like
was that was that a bit weird it's you
know and then this sort of translates to
everything like when I'm writing the
book when I'm doing YouTube stuff
podcast guests like oh did the guest
thing that was a bit weird stuff like
that
um I guess beyond the intellectual
understanding that that's probably like
the spotlight effect exists what are
some things that you found helpful in
actually coaching people through the
process of actually not caring what
people think if if that's what we're
trying to go for yeah one of the things
I do is sort of a thought experiments
with people I just had one with someone
the other day she is a person who is
really uh invested in Her Image her
physical image and she says it's just
it's what gets me through my day and I
said let's go back to the last holiday
party you attended can you think of it
and she said yes I remember it was a
Christmas party I said do you remember
what you wore she said yes I had to buy
a dress it was my husband's holiday
party for his business it was important
that I looked good I said did you spend
a lot of time figuring it out and she
said I did but it was important and I
said tell me what anyone else at the
Holiday party was wearing that night
and she paused for a long time and then
said
I can't even remember what my husband
was wearing that night and I said so do
you think that everyone else can
remember what you were wearing if you
can't remember what anyone else was
wearing and so that idea of sort of
moving through life and either
reframing the way you think about things
or these wonderful experiments I send
people on which is go grocery shopping
in your pajamas just go go in your
pajamas and see what happens because
it's not gonna destroy you if you do it
once and you might suddenly discover
that nobody cares what you look like in
the grocery store now I'm not suggesting
grocery shopping in pajamas is a
preferred Behavior it's not going to
help you but what I'm trying to do is to
get them to move through life in a way
that you don't have to put your makeup
on every day you don't have to make sure
that your tie and your pocket square and
the socks that are peeking out
underneath the Cuffs of your pants that
they're all uniquely aligned all of
those things when we can let go of them
life just gets happier and easier and
better definitely agree I think I think
that's great stuff
um one thing our viewers or listeners
might be thinking is well easy for you
to say you're a dude I'm a woman in
Corporate America and I get told when I
don't wear makeup that I look tired and
I know that people are
perhaps not consciously but at least
subconsciously judging me based on my
appearance and like how how does that
fit in because I I'm I imagine you must
have kind of talked to people about this
as well yes I always tell people let's
start off with the fact that I'm a white
straight American man with no physical
disabilities and no mental illness so I
am genetically the most fortunate human
being who has ever existed on planet
Earth I have the most advantages I've
never walked into a room and thought
nobody wants to hear from me I've always
assumed everyone wants to hear every
single thing I have to say
but what I tell people is
first if people say you look tired if
you're not wearing your makeup it's only
because everyone else in the room is
wearing makeup and if it would all just
go away we would all just look normal
right so part of the problem is not that
you look tired but you just look
different than the other people who are
highly invested in their image at this
moment so so that's sort of a construct
that if we could bring everybody down a
little that would help everyone in the
long run but ultimately it's about
performance if you are an outstanding
person at your job it does not matter if
you come to work looking tired because
if you're producing results and you are
productive and profitable and your
people are succeeding nobody will care
if you look tired and so if you're
worried about it that if I look tired
I'm not going to get the promotion I'm
looking for it's probably more to do
with what you're doing in your job
because no one has hired you for what
you look like and you're never going to
hold on to your job or be promoted
because of the way you look it is
ultimately going to come down to
Performance and we have to embrace that
I have to perform well which is really
not even as you know not results
oriented for me but process oriented you
know I know the things I have to do and
I let go of the things I can't control
but as long as you're doing the things
you know you have to do those are the
things Fall Away
can we zoom in zoom into that point what
do you mean when you say that you're a
process versus results oriented because
I know that you and I have talked about
this uh a sort of in-depth but I would I
would love to hear your take on it for
for the benefit of the viewers well you
know what I've I set goals every year
I've done it for about 15 years and I
publish them on the Internet so people
can see what my goals are and for the
first few years I was setting goals the
problem I had was I was setting goals
that I didn't actually have any control
over so I would say things like I am
going to publish a book this year and
that was actually one of my goals early
on that's a ridiculous goal because that
is dependent upon many factors outside
of my control I can say I will write a
book this year I can say I will write a
book that I deem to be outstanding I
could even write a book that is deemed
outstanding by a collection of my
friends right that they believe is
publishable but to actually get a
published book it requires an Editor to
fall in love with the book and a
publisher to agree with the editor and
an offer to be made and an agent to
agree and all of these things I have no
control over whatsoever so all of my
goals that I set with the exception of a
couple because I'm mean to myself like I
set goals about winning moth story slams
because attending the moth story slime
is just too easy for me I decided to set
a couple that are gonna
be be really cruel to me but most of
them almost all of them are I'm going to
do a thing and I'm going to bring it to
the point that I can release it to the
world and then what the world does with
it is sort of beyond my control so I
think it's so important for people to
set goals that are not dependent upon
the whims of other people because when
that happens we fail for reasons we have
no control over and I believe in failing
you know I have my average goal
completion rate for the past 15 years is
hovering right around 65 and I love that
number because if there's ever a year
that I get to a hundred percent I'm
gonna say to myself I failed to push
myself because I should never really
accomplish 100 of my goals because if I
do
I left something on the table so I love
failure I believe in not accomplishing
everything you set out to do I think
that is a signal that you have pushed
yourself beyond what was possible and I
think that's the way I want to live
what is your sort of is it is it that
you set goals at the start of the year
like what what does your goal setting
process look like it starts in December
so in December I will look at the
previous year's goals and analyze them
and decide which ones I'm going to keep
you know because they need to either
continue on to the next year uh push-ups
for example has been a goal of mine for
10 years I know that if I don't set a
goal of doing 100 push-ups a day for
five days a week I know that at some
point I might not do them but if they're
on the goals I will absolutely find a
way to do those hundred push-ups so
that's one that I'll evaluate and say it
must stay some will be completed I'll
say good I did that one I don't have to
repeat it again some will I will look at
and say my intention was to do that goal
this year I didn't end up doing it
because halfway through the year I
decided it wasn't worth it I didn't want
to do it anymore it wasn't viable it
wasn't realistic and that will fall off
and then I'll start looking in December
at new goals for the next year and at
the same time I post on my blog does
anyone have goals that they think I
should take a look at things that I
should be doing that I'm not doing and
that includes my friends who jump in and
say you're an idiot in this regard you
should really clean this up it includes
strangers who say I've been reading your
stuff for a long time here's an area
you've never explored before maybe you
want to explore it and it includes
people who say this is a thing I love I
think you might love it too you should
probably try to pursue this and then
throughout the month of December which
is always my favorite month I start
collecting those goals and I start
deciding which ones are appropriate
which ones are not and then what level I
will set for each one of those goals and
by January 1st I post it and then on
June 30th I always take an evaluation
I'm halfway through the year where am I
what are still realistic have I Let Go
of some because for whatever reason the
forces of the universe have deemed this
can no longer be a goal and I'm more
than willing to add goals on throughout
the year although honestly I do it very
very rarely I tend to hold what I have
and occasionally release a goal if it
doesn't make sense anymore
so what's an example of some of these
well some of these goals like what are
your goals for this year for example I
have 52 of them I just finished one
today okay yeah I just finished one
today uh my goal this year and has been
for the past five years is to write 100
physical letters like hey like we're
handwritten or typed that are printed
put in an envelope with a stamp and
mailed out into the world uh and I just
finished that this today I wrote a
letter and that was the 100th one that
I'm going to be sending out so so that's
important to me I have discovered that
writing letters is incredibly beneficial
and enormous number of ways like so much
goodness has come back to me from
writing letters that that will always be
a goal for me is to write 100 letters a
year what do you mean so much goodness
has come back to you oh well for example
on teacher appreciation day I wrote four
letters to four of my favorite teachers
in the world I found their addresses and
I wrote to them yesterday I had brunch
with one of them an English Professor
from 30 years ago who called me up
received my letter said come and have
brunch with me I'd love to sit down and
talk we talked for two hours which was
beautiful that's enough goodness turns
out she owns horse is new I grew up on a
horse farm my children have never ridden
horses before even though they've heard
me tell stories about being on horses
for my childhood so in two weeks I'm
going to take my children up to the
horse to the horses that she owns and
she's gonna let my kids ride their her
horses for the first time in their life
and things like that happen to me all
the time and another teacher who I wrote
to now lives about two hours south of me
on the cape on the ocean as it invited
me and my family to come for the day now
we can't make it work this summer but
we'll make it work next summer and so
part of it is just you send the letter
out because it means something to
someone it's a physical manifestation of
your thought and it's so much more
valuable than saying something kind to
someone because they get to hold on to
it and they get to reread it because
there's not enough positivity in the
world you know I also do things like I
send Pride Flags to bigoted human beings
in our country like whenever I hear a a
politician somewhere in the United
States sort of standing against same-sex
marriage I have a small collection of
Pride Flags or actually I have a large
collection of small Pride flags and I
stick them in an envelope with an angry
note and I mail it out and that makes me
feel better like and nothing good comes
back ever from that but it genuinely
makes me feel good that they're going to
open an envelope or one of their
staffers is going to open an envelope
and find a pride flag in it and they're
going to have to do something with that
probably throw it away but they're going
to have to confront it but I just it's a
good goal that I think everyone should
have but that's just one of I mean 52
you know there's lots of writing goals
for me because I'm a writer there's a
lot of performance goals like what am I
going to do in terms of being on stages
I'm building a business so there's
business related goals and then there's
lots of personal goals like
I have a best friend for the past 37
years that we don't see in we don't see
each other enough so one of my goals
this year was just make sure you see him
six times this year like we talk on the
phone we text all the time but we don't
actually physically see each other even
though we live 15 minutes apart so six
times this year every other month I'm
gonna make sure I spend time with Benji
so those kinds of goals mean a lot to me
too
when you're when you're collecting the
goals do you split them up into like
categories or is it just anything go
like yeah what are the categories yeah
so there's writing which is sort of my
that part of my business so all of the
writing goals get piled up there there's
a performance or a storytelling goal
which is standing on stages but also the
business that I'm building which is
directly related to storytelling I have
personal goals which are things like
hanging out with my friend taking one
photo every day of my kids taking a
photo of me and my wife once a week
because we never take photos together
I have organizational goals I'm sort of
an organizational not in that regard so
like my basement is always a goal
because I just can't get a hold of it
because other human beings in my house
create problems for me so and then I
always have a list of like new goals
like something that doesn't quite fit a
category it's brand new it's something
that's landed this year I'm gonna see
what it's like and so those end up there
too nice yeah I remember when we were
when I was setting my goals for the uh
no I think it was last year actually
when you and I first started to speak I
became very like yeah I want to I want
to take art lessons I want to get better
at guitar music theory piano and I tried
all these things and I actually did take
our lessons like three times a week for
a few months and we could talk twice a
week guitar lessons and twice a week
piano lessons and after a while I was
like okay this is now getting a bit much
it's time for me to drop those and just
stick them in the someday maybe list
because at some point in the future I
would like to take art lessons but at
that season of my life I felt like it
was too much and I was rocking up to the
art lessons thinking oh I know this is
supposed to be fun but I'm kind of why
am I waking up at seven in the morning
like I've got to open a zoom call
straight afterwards and kind of the
attitude that I was approaching them
with was not an attitude of like
lightness and ease and play and I like
at least for my goals I like to I like
to sort of treat them as a bit of a game
rather than something I'm taking
particularly seriously
um I guess how what's what's your
you know some some people like your your
latest book some days today which is
sick um is I guess on the surface a
productivity book and there are some
people that like oh productivity is for
losers productivity is all about just
like grinding yourself to the ground and
not having any fun uh but you don't
strike me as that kind of guy so what I
guess what's your broad approach to
these goals and to productivity in
general
I like to think that productivity is
really dream oriented that
everyone should have a dream and if they
don't they probably do and they're not
admitting to it or they do that terrible
thing where they don't actually spend
time thinking about themselves one of
the tragedies of the world is we spend
all of our time thinking about our
parents and our spouses and our children
and our business and our clients and our
customers but it's very rare that
someone sits down and just says I'm
going to think about me for a little
while how I got here you know where am I
going what are my goals as a Storyteller
I'm obsessed with finding stories so I
have something new to say on stage so
storytellers tend to be deeply curious
about themselves we're self-centered in
what I say is a positive way just
meaning we afford ourselves times to
think about us so in terms of
productivity you first have to have the
dream or a multitude of dreams you have
to have a horizon that's when I like to
think of it as what's your horizon
what's the point on the horizon but that
point on the horizon can be I've always
wanted to have a backyard vegetable
garden you know or I was talking to a
client the other day and I said well
what's your horizon goal and she said I
want to see the 50 great movies of all
time there's a list in the world I'd
have the list and I want to sit on my
couch and watch the 50 greatest movies
she said but that doesn't feel super
productive and I said that sounds
incredibly productive to me because it's
your dream so when people say
productivity sort of grinds you down I
think of productivity as it's the thing
that you want to be doing that you
should be doing more of so let's
maximize our life the things we have to
do in order to sustain life in order to
get to the things we want to do so we
don't have to think of productivity in
terms of work we can if you're one of
those people who have enormous work
dreams and and money dreams and how
streams and vacation dreams that's great
like those are all valuable goals if
that means something to you but if your
goal is to sit on the couch more and
watch black and white movies with your
husband and make sure you see all of
them before you die all the ones you're
supposed to see that's a wonderful goal
let's make sure we maximize your work
time you are for chore time let's take
away all of those little black holes of
your life that you're wasting and make
sure that we use all that so you can get
your ass on the couch more often with
your husband watching black and white
movies I think that's the way to dispel
that productivity nonsense which is we
have to grind ourselves it's just dream
oriented choose the right dream
and then productivity will make total
sense to you that's nice I like that
terminology like all right what's your
horizon goal um and I guess
we can have Horizon goals for different
areas of our life like if I imagine for
like my book The Horizon goal is oh
actually brought more more broadly I'd
like to be an author who writes books
every few years because it seems kind of
fun
um and then I guess I can break that
down into more concrete steps like is
that how you approach it you figure out
the Horizon goal and you break it down
like what's what's your process for this
yeah well I like a horizon goal because
I think that
you know if we're thinking about a dream
or that thing on the horizon I think
when people Define it very specifically
it's a mistake you know I originally
thought I was going to be a Storyteller
who told stories on stages in New York
and Boston and maybe somewhere else in
the world and if I had made that Horizon
Point sort of defined and specific I
would have only moved in that direction
I like thinking of Horizons because
that it's sort of very wide it's a
distant point that you can't quite see
it's the acknowledgment that the roads
you're on the path you're taking might
not actually land you and the place you
thought you would land but you'll land
in the vicinity it's an it's an
approximation of the dream you know even
with sort of a book I start writing a
novel it always starts with a what if
question and I think I know what the end
is going to be it never has been the end
I allow the book to sort of dictate
where the where the final moment of this
character is going to be and I just see
it as a horizon but sometimes I go wow
that was quite left of whatever I
thought it was going to land but it's in
the vicinity it's not behind me it's
always somewhere in the front so I like
to identify that idea of I'm going to be
a Storyteller but that I'm going to be a
Storyteller also allows because it's on
the horizon to be maybe I'll teach
storytelling someday maybe I'll be a
consultant about storytelling maybe
maybe an advertising company will allow
me to inject storytelling into their car
commercial which is what I've done right
all of those things are sort of on the
storytelling Horizon but it affords me
the opportunity to be flexible in terms
of what ultimately is going to happen
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal I have been a pain
customer of huel since 2017 so it's been
about six years now that I've been using
Q fairly regularly I started eating Hill
in my fifth year of medical school and
I've been using heel regularly ever
since because you know I like to be
productive I've you know my calendar is
full with a lot of things and often I
don't have the time or don't make the
time to have a particularly healthy
breakfast or a particularly healthy
lunch my favorite flavor is salted
caramel because for 400 calories you get
40 grams of protein which is absolutely
insane and you also get a decent healthy
mix of carbohydrates and fiber and fat
along with 26 different vitamins and
minerals which are all very good for the
body there's nine different flavors of
this to choose from my favorite is a the
banana version and also the Salted
Caramel version so what I do is I take
my two scoops I put them into my
NutriBullet blender type thing although
you can just use a normal Shaker if you
want I mix it up normally with water but
a little bit of milk to add a bit more
of a milkshake like consistency to it
and then I just sip that while I'm on my
desk doing my work in the morning and it
ensures that I get a very healthy
breakfast in that's nutritionally
complete rather than and some high sugar
cereal which is what I would have
defaulted to instead also heal is
ridiculously reasonably priced like a
meal 400 calories comes out to one pound
68 per meal which is super super cheap
compared to what the alternative would
be if you were ordering takeout for
example anyway if you like the idea of
getting these cheap and healthy and
nutritionally complete meals in your
diet then head over to heel.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt which are
quite nice and also a free kind of
shaker bottle type thing with your first
order so thank you so much heal for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom is just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you the app also lets you
Auto invest which is a great thing
because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started when investing and
you want to give it a go then you you
can download the app on the App Store
and if you use the coupon code Ali Ali
at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode okay so let's say I have which I
sort of do a horizon goal of I'd like to
be a musical performer of some kind
um I did this was actually when I you
know back in like 2008 when I discovered
YouTube uh the channels I was mostly
following were the YouTube music cover
artists and I'd watch them play the
piano or the guitar and sing along to
some cover of a popular song and think
damn that's sick I really want to do
something like that and I had a few full
Stars I dabbled with a few videos here
and there over the years and it was only
like 10 years later that I was like you
know what let me sit down and teach what
I know about how to get into med school
that I actually became a YouTuber so it
sort of ended up going in a completely
different direction but I have always
had in the back of my mind that
at some point someday
um I would like to
um oh yeah I'd like to explore that
interest a little bit more I love the
idea of learning how to play instruments
myself and learning music theory and
learning how to compose and arrange and
then singing either myself or with
friends to two popular songs so that's
like a vague Horizon goal I guess like I
like that would be yeah yeah that makes
sense to me yeah yeah so I think next in
terms of breaking it down or like yeah
what's the process well it sounds to me
like you're not quite sure like what
you know path that's you're going to
take to the Horizon and I and I like
that too you know I think the mistake
people would make would be I am going to
get a record contract I am going to be a
lead singer in a rock band with a record
contract that is a bad idea I think what
you've said is I want to do something in
music
and I kind of want to be a person maybe
making music and making people happy
with that music right but if that
Horizon means you know what I discovered
I'm actually a really good DJ I don't
need to learn how to play a music
because I can actually scratch and that
actually fills that need for me or it
could be turns out I can't play
instruments but what I can do is I can
find people who play them really well
and I can help them make better music
and become a music producer right that's
that's in that general area and I think
it's when people say no I will not be
happy unless I have a record contract
and I'm in a rock band and I'm
performing in arenas that's the only
thing that's going to make me happy
I think that's a terrible sort of
approach to life so I like your approach
which is I kind of want to do something
in music I think I want to play music
but you know open to other things and
then I would just do what you're doing
which is begin the exploration start
walking down the path you know all right
let me try a guitar for a while right my
wife wanted to play the guitar and then
she quickly realized you know what the
ukulele is better than the guitar it's
easier to play it's smaller and I can
use it in my kindergarten classroom so
she became a ukulele player she's pretty
good and then one day I said are you
ever gonna sing with the ukulele and she
said I don't know I'm not that good of a
singer but it turns out with the ukulele
it doesn't demand you to be a good
singer because the instrument is so sort
of
small and light and amusing that you
don't have to sort of sing really
beautifully you can just sing well so
she has become a ukulele player who
plays music to her kindergarten students
and changes the way they learn because
of it not her original goal which is I
want to play the guitar someday but it's
become this thing and all she did was
she started on the path she took
positive steps forward most people spend
an enormous amount of time thinking
about what they should do to get to the
Horizon rather than saying well this is
one possible step I could take I'm going
to take the one possible step and if
it's not the right one I will take
another possible step but I cannot tell
you how many people I meet who say well
I'm still trying to plot out my thing
and I always say all the thinking you're
doing about reaching your goal is
meaningless and useless and it doesn't
count for anything if you're just
thinking about getting there you're
doing nothing take a step forward even
if that means going online and buying a
ukulele that's the first step grade you
made a positive step today a ukulele is
coming to your home think about what the
next thing you can do is
I love that yeah
um thinking about this exact audio this
morning um because so every every
morning I carve out three or four hours
to do book stuff and I was working on uh
one of the chapters around
procrastination and how
um when we're procrastinating from a
thing that we either want to do or need
to do often the first step is actually
to just Define what is the next step
because I think that you know you know
in my in my world where people are
struggling to start YouTube channels and
stuff it's always like thinking 100
steps ahead of like oh but like what's
my Niche gonna be eventually which is
going to allow me to monetize and blah
blah blah blah blah so I was like no man
just like you know focus on like you
know get going like what is what is the
next step
and there's a line from the end of one
of Brandon sanderson's books uh
oathbringer where it's like um the most
important step a person can take is just
the next one yeah I think about that a
lot I think with any goal that I have
what is the next step I can take this
week in one sitting that will just make
progress in some way and as long as I'm
not wedded to the pace of progress or to
the destination particularly at least
it's you know it's it's creating
movement and movement generally for me
at least leads to motivation and then
makes life feel good and all that stuff
yeah well your story of how you sort of
became what you are was a perfect
example of that like
I thought I was going to be a person
invested in YouTube in the musical realm
and then one day I decided to make a
video on how I got into med school right
which never would have been your initial
thought on how this would ever happen
for you but you remained open enough to
say well let me try something else I
know what my goal is which is I want to
appear on a screen for millions of
people around the world in a educational
or inspiring way but your story is
exactly what I am talking about you know
the idea of incrementalism is so
important people don't believe in it the
idea that tiny changes accumulated over
time produce enormous results most
people want a Big Gulp a magic pill they
want to instantly have a million
subscribers they want to have a perfect
YouTube video they want to have a book
contract before they actually write the
book or even before they even write the
proposal right everyone sort of wants
this enormous leap and if you examine
the success stories which I always
believe you should do is like just
examine the success stories of people in
the world so that you can get a sense of
what those success stories are all of
them involve tiny incremental changes
piling up over time that eventually
produce enormous results but people
don't believe in it because they can't
see it immediately you know I just
recently started I learned that people
who have better balance live longer
because if you get older and you don't
have good balance you fall and those
Falls put you in the hospital and old
people in the hospital die you you know
that it's probably better than I do and
so one of the tricks I Learned was when
you're brushing your teeth stand on one
foot during the first minute of brushing
your teeth and see if you can maintain
that one foot and then switch to the
other one and so I've started doing that
and I've asked people or I've told
people this is a really good idea you
know to help you improve your balance
and someone came back to me and said
after a month well I don't really see my
balance improving
and I said well first of all you didn't
really gauge your balance you didn't
assess your balance on day one to day
30. so it's impossible for you to even
say that but I said this is incremental
change you're not even supposed to see
it you're not even supposed to expect to
see it you just have to believe that
every single day that you spend a minute
on each foot twice a day if you're
brushing your teeth twice a day which
you should be
over time the piling up of small things
will produce enormous results but you
can't expect to see the results
immediately and if you do
that's when people fail to sort of make
changes in their life that are
meaningful yeah yeah no I've I've never
really thought of this before but I
guess kind of my whole foray into
musical YouTube land
like in the four or five year period
before I actually started being a proper
YouTuber and making this Medical School
Educational content it was like on
average one video a year where you know
one one time filmed it with phones
another time got a microphone another
time got a camera another time learned
how to edit I even wrote a blog post
talking about my editing process in
Premiere Pro for making music videos and
how I discovered that if you just put
black bars at the top of the page it
like makes it look widescreen and more
cinematic and all this stuff and I guess
like all that stuff was this little
steps I was taking in the vague
direction of like hey this YouTube thing
seems kind of cool I reckon music is the
kind of way forward and that meant that
when I decided you know what let's
actually make these videos for medical
students I already had a camera I
already had a microphone I already had
known how to edit having done it like
once or twice five years ago and so that
that next step was a lot easier than it
is for a lot of my students in my
YouTuber Academy where it's just
completely overwhelming from day one and
there's a lot of overthinking that that
goes on in the process yeah it's the
steps we take
that we just have to have belief like I
opened my book with the word hope I
think hope is so important the belief
that when you're taking steps forward
somewhere down the road it's going to
help you know I made the mistake once
someone asked me how did you become a
Storyteller and in a workshop I said
you know when I was 40 I took a stage
and I just suddenly found something I
was naturally good at I got lucky at a
later point in life that I I suddenly
could do something I didn't know I could
do and my wife was in the room and she
said is that really what you think from
the back of the room she goes is that
really what you think
and I said yeah that's what I've been
telling people because I mean how do you
explain it I took a stage I won and I
instantly became one of the winningest
storytellers in moth history and
nationally recognized within a year and
she said you don't think the fact that
you've been writing stories ever since
you were 17 that you've written every
single day of your life since you were
17 years old played a role that night in
your understanding of how stories work
and I said oh I guess that's probably
true and she said and you've been a
wedding DJ for a quarter of a century
you have been standing in front of
people half drunk on a microphone
learning to speak extemporaneously
ridding yourself of every bit of
nervousness you ever could have speaking
in front of human beings you don't think
that that landed on that stage that
night and I went oh yeah I guess that's
true too and she said and you've been an
elementary school teacher all you do all
day is stand in front of 10 year olds
and tell them stories so that you can
teach them long division you just
entertain kids in order to keep them
learning that is your style of teaching
it's the worst audience in the world and
you perform every day for them she said
you don't think that helped and I had
never occurred to me but it's that like
work you're doing that you don't realize
you're doing that might someday pile
into something that changes your life
right you became a YouTuber oddly
because you became a doctor
and had you not become a doctor you
might not actually be doing what you're
doing now right and so like the work you
did which really I always say was
positive forward movement progress on a
goal regardless of what that is we have
to have hope and belief that the work
we're doing now won't necessarily land
Us in the place we expected but that the
skills and the experiences that we're
acquiring will land us in a place and I
really believe the people who take the
most steps forward in irregardless of
what the direction is they're taking
those steps forward the ones who are
actually doing things every day positive
steps forward in a Direction they think
makes sense lands them in a in a
positive place at the end of their life
or at some point in their life but I
just don't think people recognize that
because they don't credit that
incremental growth and what it could
yield it's this weird belief that people
have that they could actually predict
their own future they have so much
hubris that they think they know what
next year will be I love people who tell
me they have a five-year plan I think
it's just stupidest thing you understand
it right imagine five years ago if you
had said what my Five-Year Plan is you
would never have guessed where you are
today and that has been the same for me
for every single five years of my life
and I think it's only because I'm
constantly relentlessly finding the next
thing I want to step forward on and all
of those things will accumulate to
something
yeah that was a that was a great piece
of advice that I got from one of the
consultant Physicians that I worked with
in my fourth year of med school he asked
me you know you know I kind of got on
and we were in the emergency department
grabbing a coffee and he was like Hey
you know so what specialty do you want
to do and I was like ah yeah I've still
got three years of med school I don't I
don't need to figure it out like I I
don't really know and he said you know
what if I were you I would just pick
something and start moving in that
direction because it's a lot easier to
change direction when you're moving than
when you're static it's great I'm
stealing that and using it forever that
is good and then I decided you know
what plastic surgery is a way forward
and then I started taking steps in that
direction and then I attended this
hackathon where my skills and web design
that I've been doing for 10 years came
in handy to for us to win this prize for
this plastic surgery surgical app thing
made friends with a few plastic surgeons
joined the board of a plastic surgery
organization ended up getting hired as
like a freelance ux designer for medical
tech companies while doing my elective
which meant I could make a profit in my
life is like all these random things
happened I decided in the end I don't
want to do plastic surgery going to move
towards Obstetrics and Gynecology but
like just taking steps in that direction
led to so many interesting things that
I'm just yeah really thankful to uh Dr
Adcock for that for that piece of advice
that is great it is easier to change
direction if you're moving forward is so
great because most people are just
sitting in place contemplating what they
should do I actually I've worked with
some of you YouTubers they've come out
of your Academy and they've worked with
me privately and the thing they always
tell me is
Ali tells me I have to just make stuff
that I have to stop worrying about what
it looks like and what it sounds like
all of that will come but the first
thing you have to do is make a video and
I every time I go he's right you should
post something today and they're like
well I'm not ready today I'm like yes
you are just put up something and
they're like well what if it's bad I
said then take it down do you really
think people are scouring the internet
like if I watch a bad YouTube video it
doesn't stay with me I'm not like three
days later going that lady that lady who
wasted nine minutes of my life that
doesn't happen we just move on with our
lives right we don't worry about the
failures and so that message that you're
putting out there I hear it all the time
they don't follow it though as often as
we want them to I really believe that
people hear us but so many times they
sit and wait because of fear because of
concerns of failure because they don't
think they can do it because they're
chasing Perfection the worst thing you
could ever do in your life is to you
know try to be perfect ever but
especially out of the gate all of those
things cause them not to move forward
yeah
yeah like how how how do we get more
people to take that advice I guess like
or or rather how
you know in in your life how did you get
over that initial thing which has now
resulted in you being so prolific and
like writing and forming and all this
stuff
I I guess for whatever reason I think
probably because you know I grew up
without parents who are sort of paying
attention in any way and you know after
high school I had a tough period of life
you know homeless in jail and
violence and things like that
I think because there was never sort of
the ability to Chase
the goal the process always was valuable
to me because no one was ever at the end
with a trophy or a monetary award or
even an acknowledgment that I did
something well
and so I was never thinking
I'm gonna go do that thing so that
someone will reward me in a significant
way it was always sort of me you know I
only had me and so for me I was always
thinking
I'll just get this thing done and
that'll be a good step you know my first
novel I never expected it to be
published
but I damn well expected it to be
written because that was all on me I'm
going to write a book someday and I'm
going to write a book that I think is
good because I had maybe six starts of
novels that got 10 000 words in before
thankfully I had the the wisdom and The
Taste to read those Ten Thousand Words
and go not good this is a terrible
terrible book I cannot continue this one
but I did I knew I'll write a book
someday and I secretly believed actually
I openly believe that if I write a book
I'm going to be better than most of the
people in the world because most people
say they're going to write a book and
most don't almost no one does and
everyone thinks they will so if I just
write a book I've already achieved
something that was genuinely how I felt
and once I finished it I said to my wife
well I'll try to get it published
because you can't write a book and not
try to get it published but probably not
going to happen I told her and I had
already started my second one I said
well I can do one now I'll do two so I'm
writing my second novel I'm trying to
get the first one published never ever
ever and if it hadn't happened if all I
did was had a book that maybe I had
bound you know had a few copies made for
family members that would have genuinely
been an enormous achievement for me and
I would have recognized it as an
enormous achievement so I think it was
just for me maybe I got fortunate in the
fact that I was ignored for so often
that I had to really become
you know self assessing and because
there was no authority figure declaring
success I had to find success for myself
which was which quickly became process
oriented another thing that I really
encourage people to think about I was
just doing it with someone yesterday I
think sometimes people see a goal or a
dream is a linear process Like A to B to
C and I think that's always a mistake
too so I was working with someone
yesterday who said I want to write a
memoir and I said we'll start writing a
memoir and she said I don't know where
to start and I said do you have some
good moments that you know you want to
include she said oh yeah I said well
write those she said don't you have to
start a book at the beginning I said no
you write something just write chapter
15 if that's what you can write today
like save chapter one for the day you
can write chapter one but write whatever
you can on a given day and that applies
for everything that we're doing sort of
you know as I'm building a business is
absolutely the next thing I'm supposed
to do but if I don't want to do that
thing for some reason my motivation to
to do that task on that day is not there
I do recognize there are a multitude of
other tasks that will need to be
completed so I will go deal with those
tasks today so rather than seeing goals
as linear just see it as it's a series
of things that need to be done and in
terms of time management that helps a
lot too because if your next thing that
you have to complete takes two hours
sometimes people will just wait for a
two-hour period when there's also like a
10 minute project and a 15-minute
project and maybe a six hour project but
can actually be broken down into 10
minute increments it does not need to be
done in the full six hours all at once
so seeing your dream as
stepping stones but you get to touch
whichever one you want at any point
because you're gonna have to touch all
of them eventually that's really helpful
and then I also think momentum is
enormous when people want to lose weight
what I always tell them is
weigh yourself every day because it
fluctuates daily and start the day of
weight loss on that day when you step on
the scale and you suddenly go oh wow
that's weird I lost two pounds yesterday
you know maybe you missed lunch you did
some extra walking you didn't drink as
much water as you did and suddenly
you're two pounds less that's the best
day to start a a weight loss program
because you've already lost two pounds
like you suddenly are excited about
something excitement leads to motivation
motivation leads to momentum so you have
to just sort of start building up some
wins along the way so that's when I'm
trying to get people to like take that
first step to to do the thing I give
them easy wins like ordering that
ukulele is an easy win if you have the
money it doesn't take much to order it
and that means it's going to arrive and
that's an easy win too that's an
exciting thing you know and after it
arrives well do you have a music book
get that easy win now you have a music
book right and now can you just learn to
play an E just an e at the end of the
day you're like wow I can play an E
right it'll take you five minutes to
learn to do an E but you just you're
gonna have to learn a knee someday
that's a step you're gonna have to touch
so touch that one today so I think those
kinds of things get people moving a
little more productively or a quicker
you know rather than sitting where they
are thinking about what to do next
um I'd love to dive into the whole idea
of
um kind of making every minute count but
before we do so um how do you feel so we
we've talked a lot about sort of the
pursuit of a goal and kind of moving
forward and stuff
um in something you know I've heard some
people say and I've I've kind of
struggled with this thought process
myself which is that what's this balance
between I guess striving for the next
thing versus enjoying the present moment
I just had this conversation with my
wife I'm working on the proposal for my
next book you know even though I just
had this one come out and I have another
book sort of done I'm I'm I'm I'm way
ahead and yeah I was sort of complaining
about this book proposal I had to write
and my wife said you've published six
novels
you've published them all over the
country and all over the world and you
have two books of non-fiction now can
you just enjoy it for one damn second
can you just be happy with yourself
instead of constantly thinking you're
not good until you're working on the
next thing
and I heard her clearly
what I don't think she understands for
me is that it is the pursuit of the next
thing that is so joyous to me whether
that Pursuit is the next book or I took
my first flying lesson last week and it
might be my last flying lesson but I
wanted to try it you know
it's always the next thing I see sort of
complacency and satisfaction as
stagnation and death I I just I want to
have the widest fullest life possible
with as many things in it as I can
possibly fit so I can have as many
experiences while always prioritizing my
children my wife oddly my cats those
types of things but when those
priorities are sort of taken care of I
just want to I want to expand it as much
as possible so
you know I think that we should
celebrate our achievements
I believe in sort of my friend Jenny
just wrote a novel I think she should
have a she hasn't done anything with it
yet but I think she should have a party
that says I wrote a novel and you didn't
come and have cake I think I really
believe in that
but I think that if Jenny writes one
novel and she never writes another one
and she decides to spend the rest of her
life watching Netflix and you know
drinking craft brew on her deck and
that's what's going to make her happy I
will suggest to Jenny that when she's a
hundred she will think differently about
how she spent those years uh because the
joy and of the completion of a goal that
you've always had should just lead to
the next joy of the next completion of
the next goal you should have
this is pretty controversial I I imagine
some people are sitting here listening
or watching to this thinking that
guy like I enjoy watching Netflix for
three hours a day and I don't regret the
time that I'm I'm spending watching
Netflix for three hours a day how how is
he how can he possibly tell me that I
should be spending that time pursuing
goals instead right well again
acknowledging that goals can be I want
to have a vegetable garden I want a
little walk more I want to spend time
with friends I wanna I wanna tube down
the river more often all of those things
right
I think what I would tell those people
is that I had the unfortunate experience
of when I was 22. I I was robbed at
gunpoint you know head on the floor of a
restaurant gun to my head
uh a man counting back from three and
telling me when he hit zero he's going
to shoot me in the head and
I was absolutely
without any doubt sure that I was going
to die that day and I believed I was in
the last moments of my life
and I will tell you that I did not feel
fear or sadness or anger the only
feeling I was consumed with was regret
I instantly understood that I was 22
years old and I had failed to do
anything with my life that I had wanted
to do that looking back on my life as
joyous as parts of it were many of it
many of my parts of my life were
I realized how much time I had wasted
and how I had not done anything
and so for me that was a hinge point in
my life now it resulted in 15 years of
PTSD and a lot of problems but
ever since that day you know my Approach
is
you know my 100 year old plan you know
which is what I would suggest to your
Netflix person I enjoy watching Netflix
three hours a day to hell with him I
would say when you're a hundred will you
be happy
having lived this life the way you're
living it now the 100 year old version
of yourself who's lying on their
deathbed will that person look back and
go thank goodness you spent those days
watching killing Eve a television show
that you have no recollection of anymore
right thank goodness that you watched
all 22 seasons of Dexter because a life
without Dexter is a life unfulfilled my
suggestion would be the hundred year old
version of you is saying get off your
ass are you crazy
you're watching something that is
meaningless to you and remember I am the
person who supports the woman who wants
to watch every the best 50 movies of all
time sitting next to her husband you
know enjoying a glass of wine I'm all
for it but I think what happens is she
is taking a purposeful approach to a
dream
and it has definition and meaning and I
think the 100 year old version of
herself will look back and go thank
goodness I watched the 50 greatest films
ever made on this planet and thank
goodness I spent that time with my
husband and thank goodness we talked
about that meaningful art but when it
comes to Netflix or a phone I think what
most people do is they just follow the
path of which is at least resistance
they're just watching for watching's
sake they're just filling their hours
with things that are easy rather than
things that are hard and things that are
forgettable rather than things that are
memorable I don't think we remember most
of the television we watch and I don't
think we value it now I love television
my son and I are making our way through
every season's every episode and every
um every season of The Simpsons he's 10.
I love watching The Simpsons with my son
and we crack up about it and we make
jokes about her for days later he still
walks around to make jokes he thought
Aerosmith was a band that only existed
in The Simpsons one day it came on the
radio he goes hey these are the Simpsons
guys I'm like no no no these are guys
who were on The Simpsons right these are
the moments this is Meaningful use of my
time watching a Netflix show right that
is important to me during the pandemic
my wife my son and I went through every
single Marvel movie we had never watched
one and we often talk about how that was
a beautiful way to spend three months in
quarantine watching every Marvel movie
we will always remember that as a joyous
time in our lives but I think most
people don't approach the way that they
consume content like that I think they
are just thinking it's seven o'clock
I've eaten my dinner
now I'm supposed to sit down for three
hours and watch a television show that I
will forget about and then I will go to
bed and then I'll repeat it the next day
and when I'm 100 and I'm on my lying on
my deathbed I will be thinking my God so
many more things I could have done right
David Cassidy you know the musician I
just learned that uh he's The Partridge
Family Guy and he became world famous
David Cassidy is a world famous musician
he died a couple years ago
he was speaking to his daughter on his
deathbed the last thing he said to his
daughter and in his life was so much
wasted time
and that is a world-renowned musician
who
made music that made millions of people
happy and in the last moments of his
life he was thinking about all the time
he wasted I think that's what your
Netflix person is gonna
it's what's gonna happen to the Netflix
person but I understand them if I was
asked to like today I just want to do
whatever makes me happy I'll eat a hot
dog I'll play golf I'll have sex right
those three things that's it that and
I'll watch The Simpsons with Charlie and
every single day if I did that would
make me happy on that day but when I'm
100 I will look back and think what the
hell did you do
you really spent every single day
playing golf eating hot dogs having sex
and playing and watching The Simpsons
with Charlie with all the other things
you could have been doing in life you
couldn't have filled a few more days
with a few more things I think that's
what happens
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
full paying customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
on the verge of being lifted and I spent
like the whole year just sort of sitting
in my room making YouTube videos but
then I discovered wework and I was a
member me and Angus my team members we
were members of the wework in Cambridge
and they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop up with
me I've got some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've also got various kind of
after work events that happen like happy
hours and yoga and a few other exercise
type things and you can also take in
guests so often when guests will come
over to visit I'll say hey let's pop
into wework and we'll just work from
there for the whole day and then we'll
go out for dinner sometime in the
evening anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 of your first booking so thank you so
much wework for sponsoring this episode
there's a there's a great story that you
tell in your new book some days today
um about
um think you had a lunch with someone
and they were a few minutes late like
seven minutes late or something I wonder
if you can you can tell that story
because that's that's one that's really
really stuck with me so I always am
willing to give fledgling writers 30
minutes of my time if they will meet me
in the place that I happen to be and I
was in McDonald's that day which is
actually one of my favorite places to
meet writers at some I like the sort of
tearing away of all of what people see
as writing which is you know I need to
be at a coffee shop with smooth jazz and
a cappuccino I like to put them in a
plastic table
with a lot of noise and and Diet Coke so
she met me at the McDonald's and she was
late and so when she sat down I said
tell me what's your plan what you're
doing and she started describing this
book you know and it sounded interesting
like I was like this sounds like a good
project but I just waited for my moment
and then eventually I said as I always
say to writers I say so how much have
you written and so often almost always
the answer is oh well I haven't started
writing anything yet
and I then I said to her I said well you
were seven minutes late today and she
said I'm sorry you know she bet I'm so
sorry I'm like no no my point was not
that you were seven minutes late and I
was upset my point was I used the seven
minutes that you were late to write some
sentences you know I turned my computer
I said this is what I wrote in the seven
minutes that you were late right she was
a person who believed she could only
write in a two-hour block that her ideal
writing time was like 10 to 12 you know
that she needed to be in a certain place
in a certain mind frame which is so
often every creative person's belief
that they only work under certain
circumstances ideally so I reminded her
that during World War One there were men
in trenches wearing gas masks artillery
exploding over their heads and they were
scribbling in little books in journals
hoping that if they survived this battle
and the many battles that were to come
someday they might publish something so
thank goodness that the writers of the
1910s did not require Starbucks
smooth jazz and two-hour quiet blocks of
time for them to get their work done
because that's just not a reality
especially if you actually want to make
a thing if you want to do something like
a vegetable garden in your backyard or
write a book or create a YouTube channel
if you actually want to do it you should
want to be doing it whenever it's
possible so I I tell all of the creative
people of the world 10 minutes is
precious to you it doesn't mean in 10
minutes I can write a chapter
but you know in 10 minutes I can re-read
the last three paragraphs I wrote
earlier today and see if they're okay
and clean them up a little bit or I can
write five good new sentences so
it's just the idea that
people they just assume they need these
ideal situations in order to create
something lovely you know whereas like
Van Gogh
was like mentally unstable and
unmedicated and produced some of the
greatest work in the world you know but
had he been living in 2022 people might
have said well let's get control of some
of your mental illness first let's
experiment with some medication before
we get you painting right like it's
always this idea that everything has to
be right before we launch and that's not
true we should just launch we launch now
we're not the Space Program we're not
putting people into orbit where we have
to be careful we just have to take steps
forward and as is the case with most
people she really wasn't invested in
writing she was invested in the idea of
having written or in the idea that I can
quit my job and write from 10 to 12
every day and then have lunch with my
friends and that is the writer's life
which is as you well know not the
writer's life
nice
um yeah I I think back to that bit of
your book whenever I feel like oh you
know I should you know I should probably
do some book stuff right now but yeah
I've only got 23 minutes until you know
until this thing that I have to do and
like oh you know I could go down I could
get a coffee get a biscuit just like
lounge around a bit I can't get anything
done in 23 minutes I need I need hours
and hours you know with my with my flat
whites in my hand and like my Lord of
the Rings in my background music to get
into the Zone uh but I love the way you
put that of like in the seven minutes I
wrote some sentences I'm just thinking
that if I I should just have that
approach because like when I was you
know when I was when I was working as a
doctor
um and trying to do the YouTube thing on
the side I would use those seven minutes
blocks of time here and there to write
stuff for videos like if I'd be on the
toilet instead of scrolling Twitter on
my phone I'd be on notion typing out
some stuff for a video or if I'm waiting
eight minutes for a patient's blood
results to arrive and there's no one
else in the waiting room and there's
nothing for me to do it's like great
let's open up notion on the Windows
computers in front of me and just like
type out a few notes for a video and so
many people in my in my Academy ask like
oh but like I've got I've got a job like
how do you do YouTube alongside the job
I'm always like like man like there are
very few jobs where you don't have small
small amounts of time here and there
where you normally you normally waste
scrolling on your phone where if you
wanted to and if you really cared about
this thing I'm not saying you have to
but if you did you could potentially
spend that time opening up Apple notes
and just drafting a few bullet points
for for your next video and I think I've
got that approach to YouTube but I
really don't have the approach to the
book because for the book I've commit
I've talked myself into believing the
that like I need to I need to
have four hours and like the appropriate
coffee cup and all that crap yeah well I
wrote my fifth novel almost all of it in
faculty meetings while teaching now
admittedly it's a book of lists it's a
novel written by an obsessive list maker
so the book is told or the story is told
through list after list after list after
list but I wrote almost most all of
those lists in those moments of a
faculty meeting when something was being
said that was irrelevant to me which was
an enormous number of minutes in those
faculty meetings or I always arrive five
minutes early and I use those five
minutes and as things are wrapping up or
we have a raffle at the end of it
because that's going to make us happy
I'd just be writing lists and the beauty
of that was I didn't even need to write
on a computer I could have a Post-It
note that I'm writing a list on and that
can later be transferred into the
computer I wrote a whole book during
meetings and you know I always remind
people a book is probably about five
thousand sentences so like
incrementalism right pile up 5 000
sentences and you have a book I can't
guarantee that's going to be a good book
that depends on you and your effort and
skill and experience but it's five
thousand sentences and if I write seven
sentences here I am a lot closer to five
thousand than I was a minute ago I
really believe that that seven sentence
step forward is a significant one
especially because I know I'll do that
23 times today I'll take 23 moments in
my day to write somewhere between 1 and
50 sentences and if I just keep doing
that you know that is why I
have a pile of books you know it's it
and you know I'm a school teacher you
know I am a wedding DJ I have a
Consulting business I'm launching
another business I do I'm a minister I
officiate weddings I'm a substitute
minister at churches even though I
really don't have a lot of faith in God
I do all these things and people the
reason I wrote my book was because
people would ask me how do you do all
that you do and I would always say well
if you give me 12 hours I'll sit down
with you and I'll go through your whole
life and I'll help you out and no one
wants to do that so the book was the
answer to that question
um but yeah same thing with writing is
with everything else people get very
precious
over how a creative person works or how
creativity Works whether that creativity
is writing a book painting a painting or
figuring out how are you gonna you know
lay out your vegetable garden or my son
right he's official he's taking up
fishing this summer he loves it he's
obsessed with fishing and you know he
had his tackle box and he bought all
this gear and I said all right when are
you gonna set it up and he said right
now and I said well you got to go to bed
in 10 minutes and he goes I can get some
of it done in 10 minutes Dad and I was
like damn he is right like I was gonna
tell him don't start setting up your
tackle box now wait for the morning but
he was like no I'll get some of it done
I got 10 minutes before you're gonna
make me brush my teeth that's exactly
the attitude you have to have
nice love it
um so just uh I one of the things that
also struck me about the book was it
seems you have a pretty Cavalier
attitude towards rules and I wonder if
you can just talk about your attitude
towards rules yeah well I think rule
followers tend to be the least
productive people in the world you know
I think that
well it happened to me last night I was
with my friend Jenny
and uh she was telling me about how she
had made a mistake in her classroom as a
teacher and she got in trouble she said
I got in trouble with my principal and I
said what was trouble and she said well
I got yelled at and I said did he
actually raise his voice and she said
well no he told me what I did wrong
I said so you received feedback from
your boss on your performance
so we have to pull back trouble
and yelling to feedback from your boss
on how to fix your performance for next
time which is a normal thing that
happens in a workplace every day
but so often Jenny's a rule follower so
often rule followers see the violation
of a rule as a potentially dangerous
thing that will result in a catastrophe
catastrophic series of events that will
destroy their lives when most of the
time none of the rules actually matter
most of them are made up arbitrarily and
most of them are relevant so you know
I'm not proposing people Rob or you know
commit crimes in any way but what I'm
proposing is
test the world in terms of rules you
know one of my favorite tests I don't
know if I wrote about this in the book
is every time I do extra work as a
teacher I have to fill out a timesheet
actually in almost everything I have to
do as a teacher I have to fill out like
a list of things to the top a heading
and one of them is my name and then it
always says position
I think I'm supposed to write teacher up
there but I always write the word
upright my position is upright I've done
that for 24 years and no one has ever
said anything to me about writing the
word upright which is a signal to me
that that question is irrelevant now
it's sort of a rule that I'm supposed to
indicate my position on these forms but
by writing upright I have discovered
that that is an irrelevant rule that
that is something no one has ever looked
at and no one has ever cared when I do
and so I take that approach to most of
my life which is let me see what happens
if I don't do this thing because almost
always what will happen is someone will
say you need to do that thing and I say
oh my gosh you're right I'll do it next
time and then I know it has to be done
but I will tell you that
half of the time and every
administrative task I am required to do
at work half the time when I don't do it
nobody ever says a word to me and it
does not affect my job in any way
there's just layers upon layers of rules
in our world
the parking lot at my uh we have we
belong to this Lake Club
there's a parking lot and I invent
parking spots which make my children
crazy because they're real followers but
I just parked on the grass next to the
parking lot because all the parking
spaces are filled and I don't want to
have to go to the auxiliary parking lot
Which is far away and they go Dad this
isn't a parking spot I said I know it's
not but who's in charge here at the lake
Club it's not the police right and they
don't tick it because there's no like
meter made here at the at the lake Club
the worst thing that's going to happen
is a teenage lifeguard is going to come
over to me and say Excuse me sir you
can't park there and then I will say oh
I'm sorry I'll go park it somewhere else
now I've been doing this for four years
no one has ever said a word to me I make
parking spots up because I recognize
that there's no official in charge of
any parking lot anywhere on the planet
you can basically Park wherever you want
and unless you're like on a college
campus and maybe there's a Security even
then do they have a tow truck are they
going to tow you for parking in the
wrong place at the University at best
you're going to get a note maybe a
ticket most of the time I'm at a
university that I'm never coming back to
thank you for your ticket good luck
getting paid on that one right which is
another rule that I won't follow but the
problem is is when we follow all these
rules when we obsess
when we obsessing the expectations of
others that are unnecessary we lose time
so I encourage people to just sort of
cut every corner you can because your
life and your time are too precious to
be absorbed with bureaucracy that is
utterly unnecessary
have you have you always had this
attitude like oh can you trace it back
to like a moment where you realize that
this was a thing
the moment I can trace it back this is
crazy but it's really true I'm in
kindergarten in Mrs Dubois class and I
am building a tower of blocks during
indoor recess
and she Rings her a little about she
says recess is over and I still have a
few blocks to put on the tower
and uh she says Matt you know clean it
up and I said Yup just one sec I had to
finish the tower
and you know I'm a kindergartner so I
guess I'm taking a long time Matt clean
it up I'm like yeah yeah I'm gonna get
to it and so she comes over and she
slides her foot under the tower so that
it collapses in front of me
and I'm so mad about it I say something
I don't know what I say but it's bad
enough to get me in trouble and the
trouble is go to the corner which was a
kindergarten punishment which is you go
stand in the corner with your nose in
the corner and I was terrified of it
because only Sean trudell got sent to
the corner like the red-headed demon and
now I'm going to the corner
and I remember I went and I stood in the
corner underneath a flag and there was a
pencil sharpener and I stood in the
corner and I said to myself
it's just a corner
like this is nothing
why was I afraid of the corner
put me in the corner all day lady if I
can do what I want and I suddenly
understood that all I will ever have to
do in life at worst is trade choice for
time which is what I did in high school
all the time you know I would I would
just do what I wanted with the
acknowledgment that at the end of the
day I would have to spend an hour in
detention where I would just do my
homework which I would be doing at home
anyway you know so like there was a
beyond the school there was a stream and
Beyond The Stream there was a forest and
we were not allowed to go across the
stream into the forest one day I was
like well I'm gonna go in the forest
because I want to know what's there and
I'm just going to trade time I'm just
going to trade time to go explode the
forest which is exactly what I did I
went to the forest I the bell rang I ran
I jumped the stream I almost didn't get
in trouble like the teacher caught me at
the very end she's like did you just
jump the stream and I'm always honest I
believe in like be honest don't lie I
said yeah I went to the forest she said
you can't go to the forest I said I know
so why'd you go to the forest I said
well I wanted to see what was in the
forest she goes you're not allowed to go
to the forest I said I know y'all give
me detention and I'll go do the
detention but now I know what's in the
forest and she lost her mind because
she's a rule follower she can't
understand that whole notion of trading
choice for time and that's essentially
at worst what will ever happen when you
break a rule but most of the time
nothing happens except you go oh I'm
sorry I'll fix that and then you fix it
but remember my friend Jenny
saw
feedback from a boss as trouble and
yelling when neither one was actually
true she did not get in trouble it was
no actual consequence and he did not
raise his voice but in most people's
minds that's what happens when they get
called into their boss's office and the
boss says hey you didn't fill out that
form you didn't complete the data in
that database and you go oh my gosh I'm
so sorry I'll go do it right now that
won't happen again they'll even think I
just got in trouble you didn't get in
trouble the boss has already forgotten
about you they just need the database
done right don't do it again now maybe
trouble will happen but test the world
find where the pain points are most of
them don't exist you think there are
pain points when really there's parking
everywhere just take advantage of it
yeah I think I was very much a real
follower when I was younger because I
was very wedded to the idea of being the
good kid
um and I kind of admire my brother when
he when he was younger because when we
when we were younger because he was very
much not a rule follower and would
always do things and I'd be like oh but
like that's against the rules he's not
and he'd be like I don't care I'm gonna
do it anyway
and then and then as I as I growled
around especially once I I got to
University and started working like you
know Cambridge University is meant to be
this fancy big ass name University and
like the admin and the organization and
stuff was pretty non-existent in the
medical school and still is to the to
this day and so we'd end up on these
random placements in random hospitals in
the middle of nowhere where no one has
any idea that we're supposed to be there
even though they're technically the ones
in charge of our placement right I
remember there was one time where
um my mum was invited to the Caribbean
to give a talk at some conference and
she had a plus one and she said Gee
would you want to come along and it was
bang in the middle of my general surgery
placement I was like you know what let's
let's yeah why not I'll I'll figure
something out my mum is a rule follower
so I didn't tell her that I wasn't
actually allowed to take time off but
you know I went to the Caribbean for a
week had a great time came back and I
remember being like really terrified
because the following day was going to
be our end of placement meeting with the
head general surgeon and she was going
to be like you know I've spoken to all
the colleagues we didn't see you on
these dates
Etc and so I was like preparing all
these like reasons in my head and sort
of yeah it's fine I'll do another two
weeks of the placement if you want me to
et cetera et cetera and she came in and
she was like guys I'm so sorry I haven't
been around very much I've just been so
busy with like you know the patience and
like this and that I'm so sorry I
haven't been giving you the time you
deserve
I was just like oh my god
um everyone is making it up as they go
along and no one has it together and a
lot of these arbitrary rules and
expectations for things uh are just that
arbitrary and now my thought process if
I want to do something is like what's
what's the worst that's actually going
to happen yeah and if it's just like I
don't know a parking ticket or
equivalent or a telling off whatever
that looks what else who cares if I want
to do the thing they'll do the thing and
I feel like that's been a really useful
kind of life life hack yeah what you
just said was so important everyone is
making up everything it's weird that
some people feel like there's sort of an
archetypal
structured you know set of codified
rules so you just have to get married
and like you know discover that your
spouse thinks spoon should be separated
because that's a rule that she had when
she was a child and you didn't have that
rule and suddenly you discover that oh
some people think there is an actual
proper way to do something when really
we just made up the proper way and you
can just make up a new proper way but
that is how they live their lives my
wife is starting a new program a new
educational program she's going to learn
to teach on children of who speak other
languages Esau program and she said you
know they seem really disorganized I'm
worried and I said no be excited when
you're in a program full of disorganized
people that means there's cracks to
exploit like if they can't keep track of
their own stuff they will not be able to
keep track of you in the way they should
and that means you will be able to take
advantage of that I love being in a
situation where clearly the person on
top doesn't know what they're doing
because as soon as that happens you just
know that you can start taking advantage
of this rule breaking I'm going to take
care of myself attitude she's still
nervous about it because she's a rule
follower she wants to be in a world
where there's clearly stated rules I
want to be in a role where there's
clearly stated entirely flexible and
oftentimes avoidable rules and you know
and people who who can't enforce those
things so I love disorganization I know
that I can thrive because I can take
advantage of it
nice
um I'd love to talk a little bit about
storytelling but before we go there um
can you elaborate on what happened in
your gun situation because I imagine a
lot of people are like whoa you
gotta come to your head you thought
you're gonna die like what's the like
you're still here so what's what's going
on yeah I used to not be able to talk
about it you know it was years of
therapy that allowed me to I was
managing a McDonald's restaurant uh in
Brockton Massachusetts real tough town
and uh it was after closing the store
was closed up and I was at the safe
counting money
and
um I Heard the windows break and I knew
someone was coming and
I knew that I was in trouble because the
police had come the week before and
warned me that there were people uh
robbing restaurants and two people had
already been killed including someone
like in the Taco Bell that I could see
across the across the way they had
killed somebody there so when I heard
the glass break I knew I was in trouble
and for reasons I'll never understand I
had seven thousand dollars in my hand
and the deposit that was to go to the
bank the next morning
and I dropped it down the slot in the
back of the safe the one that dropped
the money into a box that I could not
open and it sat on the box manager has
no key
and so when they got to the office and
they put me on the ground with my
employees and they started emptying the
safe they knew right away that there
wasn't enough money here that like
there's money in the drawers there's
some change but where is the receipts
from the night and I said it's in that
box I can't open it and they didn't
believe me or they wanted to test
whether I really could open it or not so
they beat me first
and then um when that didn't work and I
still couldn't open the box uh one of
them put me on the ground and pressed my
head to the greasy tile floor and then
put the gun to my head and pressed my
head onto the floor with the gun and he
said I'm going to count back from three
you need to open that box because if I
get down to zero I'm gonna shoot you in
the head
and I it was a terrible moment for me
but oddly this hinge point because I
felt all this regret thinking I was
going to die and he pulled the trigger
on an empty gun so it clicked and then
um and then like it's hard to describe
but I sort of like I almost became an
animal I tried to crawl away I could
barely breathe they pulled me back and
they did it to me two more times where
they counted back and each time they
said this is the real time like we
killed people already we're gonna kill
you so but each time despite the fact
that I was sort of each time more losing
my mind than the last time
I was so consumed with regret in those
moments and ultimately they pulled the
trigger on an empty gun three times and
then left
um I guess I convinced them after the
third time that he really can't get this
box open so there's no point in killing
him whereas like the guy in Taco Bell
had resisted and that's why he died I
wasn't resisting I was just unable to
open that open the box with the money in
it
yeah so you know it took a long time I
fortunately met my wife I didn't
understand therapy you know so for years
I would just not be able to tell that
story hear the clicking of a gun in the
middle of the day wake up in the middle
of the night screaming every night with
a nightmare and then eventually I met my
wife and
she said what's going on and I said well
you know I have nightmares at night I
said you know how some people play
tennis and some people collect stamps
this is my thing and she's like that's
not a thing like what's going on with
you is not a thing so it took a long
time PTSD is a difficult thing to deal
with and it's still to this day I still
have moments but but I'm much much
better now and
you know I would never ever wish it on
anyone my goal always in life is I don't
ever want that to happen to anyone but
what I do want is please listen to what
I learned in that singular moment like
it was an odd blessing to truly believe
you're at the end of your life I've
worked with a couple other people
actually who have worked with me who
knew near-death survivors like me now
mine wasn't a near death it turns out
because the gun was empty but I believed
I was going to die and I'll never forget
I was having dinner in a diner one night
with one of these guys and he says I
know three of you three people who are
at the end of their life and
miraculously managed to survive he said
all three of you are the same they're
you're all the same in your approach to
life you're all the same on your like
let's make sure this this moment counts
you know you're all the same on like
something bad is happening but at least
it's memorable you know my wife and I
and my kids got caught in a lightning
storm in New York last week while we
were touring the Intrepid we left at the
wrong moment we're under a bridge in a
lightning storm there's a pipe pouring
water out on us you know you know it all
the Ubers are canceling us and I said
you know what we're never going to
forget this you know and my wife was
like I know you believe that but can we
get out of this situation and I'm like
I'm trying to get us out but let's just
all acknowledge that we're so lucky to
be having a moment that we'll never
forget because so many moments in our
lives are utterly forgettable at least
we're having a memorable one and um
that's the approach that people have who
have sort of faced the end and managed
to you know take a step back so I want
people to just learn from it without
having to experience it
yeah thank you thank you so much for
sharing um my understanding is that this
is not the only near-death experience
you've had and you've actually been like
brought back from from the grave um well
what what was the deal with that right
so twice in my life oddly I have stopped
breathing my heart has stopped beating
and paramedics have restored my life
through CPR uh when I was 12 I was stung
by a bee not knowing that I'm allergic
you know back in the time when nobody
was allergic to anything and I found
myself in my house alone
having an allergic reaction to the bee
sting I didn't even know I didn't know
what was happening because I had been
stung by bees before and never had a
reaction it was a particular B and um I
actually I oddly called my mother who
was in the hospital having back surgery
at the time it was in the times when you
could actually have a direct line to a
hospital room so I called her room and
said my I can't breathe and she didn't
know what was happening but she said
call 9-1-1 but it was also in a time
when phones were connected to the wall
by a cord and that I was on the floor on
the phone and I couldn't stand up to
hang the phone up to get a dial tone to
call 9-1-1 you couldn't disconnect
unless you hung the phone up back then
and so my mother had the woman in the
bed next to her call 9-1-1 for her and
send the ambulance to my house and my
mother heard me
go unconscious heard the paramedics they
had to break the door down because for
some reason I had locked the door when I
came in she heard the paramedics saying
like he's not breathing I don't have a
pulse she listened to the CPR they
didn't know she was on the phone like
screaming
um but they managed to get me back and
then um
and then five years later I was 17 I was
in a head-on collision I went through
the windshield of a car got hung up
halfway through and
um again on the way to the hospital in
the back of an ambulance I stopped
breathing my heart stopped beating and
uh paramedics ucpr again to restore my
life the difference though I know it
sounds crazy
the difference is that in both of those
circumstances as traumatic and horrible
as they were I didn't think I was dying
either time
like in the bee sting I closed my like I
went unconscious but I wasn't thinking
I'm going to die I thought something's
wrong with me and that everything went
black
and I go through the windshield I'm
conscious completely I'm in shock
thankfully because I don't want to
describe the injuries but they're
horrific
uh but I managed to pull my head out of
a windshield and climb out of a car and
I'm just I am destroyed I wasn't wearing
a seat belt I was 17 and stupid and uh
but I'm in the back of an ambulance I'm
I'm they're getting ready to move me to
the ambulance the snow's falling because
it's a snowy day and I remember the snow
was falling in my eyes and I closed my
eyes
and the next moment I'm in the back of
an ambulance is a woman straddling my
waist pounding on my chest and some guys
trying to force a tube down my throat
and I'm coughing it up
I didn't know I was gonna die either
so I can retrospectively look back and
go oh my God I almost died twice
but I didn't feel any regret because I
didn't know at the moment that I was
dying so even though those moments
should have been wake up calls to me
they were not because I didn't
understand the perilous situation I was
in it wasn't until I was 22 and faced
with a moment where I actually thought I
was going to die that I had that
understanding about what it means to not
have to not have done what you wanted to
do so um it's odd now my therapist will
say those other two moments probably
really primed you
for the for the moment with the gun and
and the exceptionally difficult case of
PTSD that I had was probably the result
of the gun but also
going through a windshield and being
stung by a bee and all of that stuff
that came after that he you know he
pointed out probably rightfully so that
you were well primed for a terrible case
of PTSD when that guy put the gun to
your head so
but they didn't change my life I did not
change my life at 12 and I did not
change my life at 17. I did not change
my life until I was 22.
so what did you start doing from 22
onwards like what I guess you had this
realization that ah I you know life
filled with regret what what happened
next
well I had just stopped being homeless
when I got the job you know I was
homeless for a period of time I I was
arrested for a crime I did not commit
and when I got arrested I was jailed and
then released on my recognizance but I
immediately lost my job and then I lost
my home for a bunch of reasons and I
didn't have any parents my parents threw
me out when I was 18 and I was on my own
for the rest of my life so I was
homeless for a period of my life and
then some people who I knew former
employees at a McDonald's that I managed
found out I was homeless and rescued me
took me into their house and back in the
90s you couldn't get a job unless you
had a phone and you couldn't have a
phone unless you had a wall to put the
phone on because no phones were mobile
back then so once I was living with Mary
and Jerry I was sharing a room with
their goat they had an indoor goat and I
shared the room with the goat a little
Pantry that they converted to a bedroom
for me with the goat once I had the
phone though I could get a job and so
you know I had to get jobs because I had
to pay for an attorney because the
courts wouldn't provide me with one for
lots of reasons that are stupid and so I
was working 85 hours a week at two jobs
I was working actually for a bank oddly
even though I was on trial for Grand
Larceny and I was closing that
McDonald's at night I know it's crazy I
actually in the trial the bank I go to
work for is the bank where I was
supposed to drop a deposit for
McDonald's the one that goes missing
that I've arrested for so I'm actually
working for the bank that testifies
against me in the trial and I'm working
for McDonald's even though McDonald's
also testifies against me in the trial
so it's quite a story but eventually you
know after the robbery I have to get
myself out of this legal trouble so I'm
already working 85 hours a week but four
months after the robbery I'm declared
um not guilty
and so I'm free to do what I want to do
and I immediately for the first time in
my life I go to college I go to a
community college because they'll allow
me in for free because I'm completely
poor
and I start um I take classes I join the
debate team I start writing for the
newspaper I'm working at a McDonald's
restaurant again now I'm managing
McDonald's 50 hours a week while I'm
going to school full time and working
for the newspaper and I'm on the debate
team I become the president of the
National Honor Society there and I get
involved in student government people
ask me like how did you do all that and
work 50 hours a week and I say after
you're homeless and in jail and you have
a gun to your head and you think you're
going to be in prison for 10 years
nothing else is hard I was just so
excited to be taking a step forward and
so I got my job at McDonald's and I went
to college and then I graduated from MCC
this community college and I did well
enough that Yale and Trinity College and
a bunch of very well respected
universities offered me free rides to
their schools and so um I ultimately I
went to Trinity College in Hartford
Connecticut to get an English degree
and there's this there's a situation
here in Hartford where you can take a
class at another school a Consortium of
schools exists so I knew I wanted to be
a teacher and a writer but Trinity
didn't have a teaching program so I did
my English degree there and then through
this Consortium I went to an all women's
college
like a one town over to get a teaching
degree and I went over there and they
said well first it's an all women's
college and I said I know but through
the Consortium I am allowed to take a
class here right and they said yes
technically you can they said but why do
you want to take five classes I said
well I want to do a teaching program
here and they said no the Consortium is
really just so if you can't get a class
at your home school you could get it
here if it doesn't fit your schedule
I said
but can I take five classes through the
Consortium there's nothing again rule
following right there's nothing here in
this book that says I can't take as many
classes as I want through your
Consortium
and she said so you're going to take
eight classes this semester you're going
to take five education classes with us
and three English classes of Trinity and
I said yes and she said nobody does that
and I said well I'm going to do it she
says that's like a loophole that you're
exploiting and I said yes now you
understand and so that's what I did I
went to two colleges simultaneously
through the loophole so that by the time
I graduated I had an English degree and
a teaching degree simultaneously and but
all of it people and I was also working
full-time at McDonald's and part-time at
a Writing Center and I was launching my
DJ business at the time and I part of me
thinks how did I actually do that like
it really does seem a little impossible
but I always say to myself I was
homeless I was facing prism
I was you know I was hopeless and all
you have to do is take someone who's
hopeless and give them a little hope and
nothing seems as hard anymore so that's
how I eventually got to where I wanted
to be
um but you can see how my life
instantaneously changed I was not going
to suffer regret anymore I was going to
maximize every moment I had to get to
where I wanted to be as quickly as
possible
that's incredible incredible stuff like
um for for people who are listening who
like we we glossed over a bunch of you
know like arrested for a crime I didn't
commit like the bank robbery situation
the second first time around et cetera
Etc
um a lot of these stories are in story
worthy and a few a few of them are in
the new book as well so this is a nice
little teaser that if you want to uh
hear more of Matthew on Audible or read
more of Matthew in print or on Kindle
then by all means uh check these books
out because because they're amazing
thank you I always I'll just add I just
I never want people to think I'm sort of
special in some way you know sometimes
people hear that story and they're like
my God that guy and you know if my wife
was here she'd be like he's not that
special like you know he works really
hard and he's got this weird perception
of life that admittedly has allowed him
to do all these things like he sees the
world in a way that is different than
other people only because
you know because of moments in my life
but I always want people to know that
like I really believe everyone can do
that my wife at our book launch someone
said what's Matt's best quality and she
said it is his genuine belief that every
single person in the world can do what
he's doing if they apply themselves and
I do I believe that every person can do
what I just described I think you could
work 50 hours a week and get two degree
programs and and work for the newspaper
and dual is launch a business I believe
everyone could do it I'm not sure if you
should or if you should even want to
right and you probably don't need to you
probably aren't homeless facing prison
no parents to ever help you no safety
net of any kind like I had to do it
because of my life circumstances but it
doesn't mean you couldn't and if you
believe that you could do it then
imagine all the other things you could
be doing instead I just I I never want
people to think that I'm special in some
way because truly I'm not I'm a really
average guy I'm an ordinary guy who's
applied himself
you know relentlessly to making sure he
gets the things that's done that he
wants to get done and you can do that
too
yeah I'm just kind of thinking of uh I
was speaking to a friend the other day
who has has these dreams like she wants
to launch a YouTube channel she wants to
like have her own freelance business etc
etc and you know we were kind of talking
through it I was like all right cool so
you know what what are you doing this
evening and she was like oh you know
like from you know I'll probably get
home from work at like 7 p.m and then
you know it takes an hour to cook food
and okay cool then what do you think
from eight it's like oh yeah and then I
need about two hours to wind down for
the evening because I find that it's
like you know I find that
um yeah in the evening I can't really
concentrate and I just find that
watching TV helps me helps me helped me
really wind down I was like okay cool
and then then she was like oh yeah and
then I sleep at 10 because I need to get
my eight hours of sleep and then I wake
up at six and then I go to work and and
I kind of do this thing
and I was like okay um I mean sure
that's that's fine if that's all if you
wanna you wanna go for but like do you
do you really need those two hours of
wind down time every night she was like
oh yeah yeah you know any you know I've
I've got to have those two hours because
then I can't like function if I don't
have those two hours I was like okay you
know part of me was very skeptical about
um
Another Part Of Me was like I mean I
don't want to deny her lived experience
and then maybe she's got stuff going on
that I don't know anything about
but then I was thinking like when you
have people who are in a desperate
situation
like you know uh single parents raising
kids and working two jobs to make ends
meet and stuff
those people are not the ones
complaining that they need two hours of
downtime for their mental health and for
their uh whatever and and there's this
yeah I'm I'm never really sure how to
respond to that Beyond okay fair enough
you know if that's what you want to do
then that's totally fine because I don't
want to get into the territory of like
no you're actually wasting those two
hours and actually you could do the
thing because
everyone has problems I've done anything
about yeah is is is that something that
kind of Vibes with you at all yeah
here's what I would have told her
because I get this all the time yeah I
would have said
you need two hours of downtime but is it
possible only one
can we try one hour of downtime and one
hour of productivity right so we start
with that so you're not taking away
everything that she needs but you're
suggesting that perhaps you don't need
as much as you do right so let's try
that for a little while you also
mentioned that you need eight hours in
bed every night so admit instantly I'd
analyze her sleep I'd be like well
describe your sleep to me which I'm sure
is by the way not eight hours of sleep I
am sure she gets into bed there might be
a TV in the room there is a phone in her
hand there's a book being read uh she
probably doesn't meditate she probably
doesn't have white noise she probably
doesn't have a consistent sleep cycle on
the weekends which is screwing up her
ability to fall asleep quickly she's
probably using a snooze button in the
morning she's probably lounging in bed
the eight hours of sleep is probably
seven hours of sleep and one hour of
occupying the bed in a non-productive
way right so can we take away maybe an
hour of sleep which is not really I'm
taking away an hour of bedtime not sleep
time like can we recapture two hours
because two hours just do the math for
her two hours every day over the course
of a year is an enormous amount of time
and you will accomplish many many things
I had a friend named Erica who came to
me and said Matt I have my third kid now
and I've lost all the time for myself
and I know you always find time for
yourself you play a lot of golf and
poker and back like and you do all these
things how do you do it and I said the
first thing I want you to try Erica is I
just want you to sleep one hour less I
want you to she used to get up at six I
said get up at five just get up at five
and and also use from five to six to do
all the things you want to do which for
her was exercise she had lost her
ability to exercise and eat well use
from five to six to exercise and get
your meals ready so that you can eat
well for the day and I said and if it
doesn't work because you genuinely need
that extra hour of sleep go right back
to it but I just think that we we
establish these habits and we assume
they are a must rule followers right she
is a rule follower she is I need two
hours to to wind down could it be 90
minutes
could it be 60 Minutes could it be 30
minutes right and the same thing with
the sleep so I would do that with her
and I would look to recapture an hour or
two hours because an hour even over the
course of a year is 365 hours divide
that by 24 you suddenly found days of
your life that you can now do use to to
do what you want to do but I think
people get trapped in the
and that sort of rule-making
habit-forming belief that this is the
way they must live because change is
hard because you know as I've been
telling people on this book tour
I believe most human beings follow the
path of least resistance they are
watered down the mountain they are doing
what people tell them to do what the
universe tells them to do and what some
weird
version of themselves in their head is
telling them what to do and I think that
the hard thing and the right thing or
the same thing and that the most
successful people in the world are the
ones who do not follow the path of
resistance they pick the point on the
horizon that they want to aim at and
regardless of what is in front of them
that is the pursuit that they have I
think most people don't do that
Matthew thank you so much there's been a
a fantastic conversation we were in I
was intending to talk to you about
storytelling but as usual we have gone
you know
and yeah it would be great to have a pot
too possibly in person when I come to
the US or if you're ever in London would
be great to do this in personally we can
Riff on storytelling on homework for
life and all the different things and
that'd be amazing so much more to talk
about yeah um and for anyone who's left
this conversation wanting more
definitely check out um well the two
non-fiction books of yours that I've
read story worthy and someday is today
and you also have these six novels which
I need to read at some point
the non-fiction stuff is the stuff where
I like even even within them even within
those you have like these incredible
stories that often move me to tears and
everyone every single person I've ever
recommended story worthy to at least
because that's the one I read two years
ago has been like oh my God this book is
sick so yeah I just want to say massive
thank you too thank you all that all
that you do all that you put out into
the world
um where can people learn more about you
where can people find out about your
stuff if they want to if they want to
reach out I have to just go to
matthewdx.com they can find everything
right there all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye